all this talk of primes got me hungry
for primes
you uh your blog post the beauty of
bounding gaps a huge
discovery about prime numbers and what
it means for the future of math
can you tell me about prior numbers what
the heck are those what are twin primes
what are prime gaps what are bounding
gaps and primes what are all these
things
and what if anything or what exactly is
beautiful about them
yeah so you know prime numbers
are one of the things that number
theorists study the most and have
for millennia they are numbers
which can't be factored and then you say
like like five and then you're like wait
i can't factor five five is
five times one okay not like that that
is a factorization it absolutely is a
way of expressing five as
a product of two things but don't you
agree there's like something trivial
about
it it's something you can do to any
number it doesn't have content the way
that if i say that 12 is 6
times 2 or 35 is 7 times 5 i've really
done something to it i've broken up so
those are the kind of factorizations
that count
and a number that doesn't have a
factorization like that is called prime
except historical side note one
which at some times in mathematical
history has been deemed to be a prime
but
currently is not and i think that's for
the best but i bring it up only because
sometimes people think that
you know these definitions are kind of
if we think about them hard enough we
can figure out which definition is true
no there's just an artifact in
mathematics so yeah
so which definition is best for us
for our purposes well those edge cases
are weird right so uh
so so it can't you can't be it doesn't
count when you use yourself
as a number or one as part of the
factorization
or as the entirety of the factorization
so the so you somehow get to the meat of
the number
by factorizing it and that's seems to
get to the core of all of mathematics
yeah you
take any number and you factorize it
until you can factorize no more and what
you have left is some big pile of primes
i mean by definition when you
can't factor anymore when you when
you're done you can't
break the numbers up anymore what's left
must be prime you know 12 breaks into
two
and two and three um so these numbers
are the atoms the building blocks
of all numbers and there's a lot we know
about them but there's much more we
don't know them i'll tell you the first
few there's 2
3 5 7 11.
by the way they're all going to be odd
from the non because if they were even i
could factor out 2 out of them
but it's not all the odd numbers 9 isn't
prime because it's 3 times 3.
15 isn't prime because it's 3 times 5
but 13 is where were we 2 3 5
7 11 13 17 19
not 21 but 23 is etcetera etcetera okay
so you could go on
how high did you go if we were just
sitting here by the way your own brain
continuous without interruption would
you be able to go over 100
i think so there's always those ones
that trip people up there's
there's a famous one the groton deak
prime 57 like sort of
alexander groddendyk the great algebraic
geometer was sort of giving
some lecture involving a choice of a
prime in general and somebody said like
can't you just choose a problem he said
okay 57 which is in fact not prime it's
three times
19. oh damn but it was like
i promise you in some circles it's a
funny story okay um
but um there's a humor in it
but yes i would say over 100 i
definitely don't
remember like 107 i think i'm not sure
okay like
so is there a category of uh
like fake primes that that
are easily mistaken to be prime like 57
i wonder yeah so i would say
57 and take a small 27 and 51
are definitely like prime offenders oh i
didn't do that on purpose
oh well done didn't do it on purpose
anyway they're definitely ones that
people
uh or 91 is another classic seven times
13. it really
feels kind of prime doesn't it but it is
not yeah
um but there's also by the way but
there's also an actual notion of
pseudoprime which is a which is the
thing with the formal definition which
is not a psychological thing
it is a prime which passes a primality
test
devised by fermat which is a very good
test which
if if a number fails this test it's
definitely not prime
and so there was some hope that oh maybe
if a number passes the test then it
definitely is prime that would give a
very simple criterion for formality
unfortunately
it's only perfect in one direction so
there are numbers
i want to say 341 is the smallest
uh which passed the test but are not
prime 341 is this test easily
explainable or no
uh yes actually um ready let me give you
the simplest version of it you can dress
it up a little bit but here's the basic
idea
uh i take the number the mystery number
i raised two to that power
so let's say your mystery number is six
yeah are you sorry you asked me are you
ready
no i might you're breaking my brain
again but yes let's let's let's do it
we're going to do a live demonstration
um let's say your number is six
so i'm going to raise two to the sixth
power okay so if i were working out i'd
be like that's two cubes squared so
that's eight times eight so that's 64.
now we're going to divide by six but i
don't actually care what the quotient is
only the remainder
so let's see 64 divided by six
is uh well it's it there's a quotient of
10 but the remainder is 4.
so you failed because the answer has to
be 2.
for any prime let's do it with 5 which
is prime
2 to the fifth is 32 divide 32 by five
uh and you get six with a remainder of
two
well the remainder of two here for seven
two to the seventh is 128 divide that by
and let's see i think that's 7 times 14
is that right no
7 times 18
is 126 with a remainder of 2 right 128
is a multiple of seven plus two so if
that remainder
is not two then that's definitely not
that it's definitely not
prime and then if it is it's likely a
prime but not for sure
it's likely prime but not for sure and
there's actually a beautiful geometric
proof which is in the book actually
that's like one of the most granular
parts of the book because it's such a
beautiful proof i couldn't not give it
so you
you draw a lot of like opal and pearl
necklaces
and spin them that's kind of the
geometric nature of the of this proof of
female's little theorem um
so yeah so with pseudo primes there are
primes that are kind of faking if they
pass that test but there
are numbers that are faking it that pass
that test but are not actually prime
um but the point is
um there are many many many
theorems about prime numbers um
are there like there's a bunch of
questions to ask is there an infinite
number of primes
uh can we say something about the gap
between primes as the
numbers grow larger and larger and
larger and so on
yeah it's a perfect example of your
desire for simplicity in all things you
know it would be really simple
if there was only finitely many primes
yes and then there would be this
sim finite set of atoms that all numbers
would be built up right
that would be very simple and good in
certain ways but it's completely false
and number theory would be totally
different if that were the case it's
just not true
um in fact this is something else that
euclid knew so this is a very very old
fact like much before long before we had
anything like modern numbers that primes
are infinite
the primes that there are that by the
end there's an infinite number of primes
so what about the gaps between the
primes right so so one thing that people
recognized
and really thought about a lot is that
the primes on average
seem to get farther and farther apart as
they get bigger and bigger in other
words it's less and less common
like i already told you of the first ten
numbers two three five seven four of
them are prime that's a lot 40 percent
if i looked at you know 10 digit numbers
no way would 40 of those be prime being
prime would be a lot rarer
in some sense because there's a lot more
things for them to be divisible by
that's one way of thinking of it it's
it's a lot more possible for there to be
a factorization because there's a lot of
things you can try to factor out of it
as the numbers get bigger and bigger
primarily gets rarer and rarer
and the extent to which that's the case
that's pretty well understood but then
you can ask more
fine-grained questions and here is one
um
a a twin prime is a pair of primes that
are two apart
like three and five or like 11 and 13
or like 17 and 19. and one thing we
still don't know is
are there infinitely many of those we
know on average they get farther and
farther apart but that doesn't mean
there couldn't be like
occasional folks that come close
together
and indeed uh we think that there are
and one interesting question i mean this
is
because i think you might say like well
why how could one possibly have a right
to have an opinion about something like
that
like what you know we don't have any way
of describing a process that makes
primes like sure you can like
look at your computer and see a lot of
them but the fact that there's a lot
why is that evidence that there's
infinitely many right maybe i can go on
the computer and find 10 million well 10
million 10 million
is pretty far from infinity right so how
is that how is that evidence there's a
lot of things
there's like a lot more than 10 million
atoms that doesn't mean there's
infinitely many atoms in the universe
right i mean on most people's physical
theories there's probably not as i
understand it
okay so why would we think this
the answer is that we've that it turns
out to be like
incredibly productive and enlightening
to think about primes
as if they were random numbers as if
they were randomly distributed
according to a certain law now they're
not they're not random there's no chance
involved
it's completely deterministic whether a
number is prime or not and yet
it just turns out to be phenomenally
useful useful in mathematics
to say even if something is
governed by a deterministic law let's
just pretend it wasn't
let's just pretend that they were
produced by some random process and see
if the behavior is roughly the same
and if it's not maybe change the random
process maybe make the randomness a
little bit different and tweak it and
see if you can find a random process
that matches the behavior we see and
then maybe you predict that
other behaviors um of the system are
like that of the random process
and so that's kind of like it's funny
because i think when you talk to people
at the twin prime conjecture
people think you're saying wow there's
like some deep
structure there that like makes those
primes be like close together again and
again
and no it's the opposite of deep
structure what we say when we say we
believe between prime conjecture is that
we believe the primes are like sort of
strewn around pretty randomly and if
they were then by chance you would
expect there to be infinitely many twin
primes and we're saying yep we expect
them to behave just like they would if
they were random dirt
the you know the fascinating parallel
here is
i just got a chance to talk to sam
harris and he uses the prime numbers
as an example often i don't know if
you're familiar
with who sam is he uses that as an
example
of there being no free will
wait where did you get this well he just
uses
as an example of it might seem like this
is a random number generator
but it's all like formally defined so if
we keep
getting more and more primes then
like that might feel like a new
discovery and that might feel like a new
experience but it's not
it was always written in the cards but
it's funny that you say that because a
lot of people think of like
randomness uh the fundamental
randomness within the nature of reality
might be the source
of something that we experience as free
will and you're saying it's like useful
to look at prime numbers as
um as a random process
in order to prove stuff about them but
fundamentally of course it's not a
random process
well not in order to prove some stuff
about them so much as to figure out
what we expect to be true and then try
to prove that and here's what you don't
want to do try really hard to prove
something
that's false that makes it really hard
to prove the thing if it's false
so you certainly want to have some
heuristic ways of guessing making good
guesses about what's true so yeah
here's what i would say let's you're
going to be imaginary sam harris now yes
like
you are talking about prime numbers and
you are like but prime numbers are
completely deterministic
and i'm saying like well but let's treat
them like a random process
and then you say but you're just saying
something that's not true they're not a
random process or deterministic and i'm
like okay great you hold to your
insistence that it's not a random
process meanwhile i'm generating insight
about the primes that you're not because
i'm willing to sort of pretend that
there's something that they're not in
order to
understand what's going on yeah so it
doesn't matter what the reality is what
matters is
what's uh what framework
of thought results in the maximum number
of insights
yeah because i feel look i'm sorry but i
feel like you have more insights about
people if you
think of them as like beings that have
wants and needs and desires and do stuff
on
purpose even if that's not true you
still understand better what's going on
by treating them in that way don't you
find look when you work on machine
learning
don't you find yourself sort of talking
about what the machine is what the
machine is trying to do
in a certain instance do you not find
yourself drawn to that language
well oh it knows this it's trying to do
that it's learning that
i'm certainly drawn to that language to
the point where i
received quite a bit of criticisms for
it because i you know like
oh i'm on your side man so especially in
robotics
i don't know why but robotics people
don't like to
name their robots or they they certainly
don't like to gender their robots
because the moment you gender a robot
you start to anthropomorphize
if you say he or she you start to you in
your mind construct like a
um like a life story in your mind you
can't help it
just like you create like a humorous
story to this person you start to
hit this person this robot you start to
project your own
but i think that's what we do to each
other and i think that's actually really
useful for the engineering
process especially for human robot
interaction
and yes for machine learning systems for
helping you build an intuition about a
particular problem
it's almost like asking this question
you know when a machine learning system
fails in a particular edge case
asking like what were you thinking about
like
like asking like almost like when you're
talking about to a child
who just does something bad you're
you want to understand like what was um
how did they see the world maybe there's
a totally new maybe you're the one
that's thinking about the world
incorrectly and uh yeah that
anthropomorphization process i think is
ultimately good for insight and the same
is
i i agree with you i tend to believe
about free will
you